[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
sommerliches Tiramisu aber nicht auf die
klassische Art also nicht ganz normal
geschichtet sondern wir machen eine
Tiramisu Rolle ich finde die sieht
einfach cool aus und die ist auch sehr
sehr schnell und einfach zubereitet ich
habe jetzt hier Frischhaltefolie auf
meine Arbeitsfläche das macht's gleich
einfach leichter ist eng aufzuräumen
darüber kommt aber ein Backpapier
so das hilft einfach dass die löffelbis
gleich einfacher Abkommen und ich starte
jetzt direkt mit dem Rezept und falls
ihr euch fragt wo steht denn hier die
ganz genau Mengenangaben die stehen
immer unten in der Infobox also in der
Videobeschreibung einfach aufklappen so
wir starten natürlich ganz klassisch mit
Löffel diskrett die werde ich in Kaffee
trinken ich habe mir aber auch schon
gedacht wäre das Ganze koffeinfrei
möchte kann auch einfach Milch verwenden
aber ich liebe Kaffee
und dann wird das hier angereinigt ich
zeige euch das gleich
[Musik]
so zwei Sachen sind dabei wichtig einmal
dass ihr die Zuckerseite nach unten geht
einfach damit es später einfacher zu
lösen ist und dass ihr die
Löffelbiskuits nur zwei Sekunden in den
Kaffee tun also jetzt nicht in die 10
Sekunden lang oder sowas weil in dem
Moment wo das jetzt hier an der Seite
ruht wird es schön weich und dann könnt
ihr das gleich schön aufräumen deswegen
mache ich doch erst das und dann die
Creme und für die Creme braucht ihr nur
wenige Zutaten so ganz typisch Tiramisu
natürlich Mascarpone gebe ich jetzt in
die Schüssel meiner Küchenmaschine
wichtig ist dass die Zutaten kalt sind
so Sahne ist nämlich auch ganz kalt aus
dem Kühlschrank dann nehme ich immer von
Kaufland die 500 Gramm Packung weil ich
habe einen großen Sahne verbraucht und
ich finde das immer ganz praktisch wie
gesagt auch super super kalt aus dem
Kühlschrank gebe ich direkt mit dazu
denn nur dann funktioniert das ähm dass
ihr das zusammen aufschlagt
so für die süße noch Puderzucker der hat
bei mir jetzt irgendwie keine Klümpchen
oder so durch Lagerung wenn ihr euch
sicher gehen möchtet sieht das gerne
dazu bei mir passt es aber und ich
möchte aber Vanillegeschmack und gleich
kommt er noch Erdbeer dazu daher ein
bisschen Vanilleextrakt und dann wird
das Ganze erstmal nur langsam verrührt
so dass es sich verbindet und dann könnt
ihr mit der Geschwindigkeit immer
schneller gehen und währenddessen lass
ich auch Sahnefest einsehen
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt noch tiefgekühlte
Erdbeeren kurz in der Mikrowelle antauen
lassen also nicht erwerben lassen und
anschließend püriert ich habe Tiefkühl
Erdbeeren persönlich immer da die wenn
eine erntefrisch tiefgefroren und später
für die Deko nämlich auch noch frische
Erdbeeren aber wenn es gerade mal keine
Saison ist und ihr habt Lust auf Erdbeer
Tiramisu könnt ihr das mit dem Tiefkühl
erkennen das ganze Jahr über machen so
jetzt werdet ihr viel Creme haben das
ist auch so bedachten bisschen was kommt
nämlich jetzt hier auf die löffelbis und
dann solltet ihr aber auch noch was zum
bestreichen und für die Deko übrig haben
daher nicht alles drauf tun vor allem
wenn es ein rollt dann quetscht die
Creme auch immer so ein bisschen nach
vorne daher Last an einer Seite ruhig
eines anderthalb Zentimeter frei damit
ihr das beim Aufräumen eben nicht
komplett rausdrücken so ich nehme jetzt
eine Winkelpalette und verstreiche jetzt
erstmal wirklich nur so eine
ja was ist das denn so ein halber
Zentimeter also wirklich nicht viel und
darüber kommt dann unser Erdbeerpüree
und dann wird eingeräumt
[Musik]
nachdem wir das ganze schön eng
eingerollt habt einfach noch mal mit der
Frischhaltefolie ein wenig enger drücken
also so dass es wirklich super super eng
ist damit es nicht eine flache Rolle
wird sondern sie schön rund bleibt an
den Seiten könnt ihr das auch noch mal
ein Zwiebeln daher fand ich eben den
Trick mit der Frischhaltefolie super so
könnte das auch schön anheben und jetzt
für 4 Stunden kühlen in der Zeit wird
das Ganze schön fest und sitzt noch mal
und dann könnt ihr dann nachher nämlich
auch schöne Scheiben von abschneiden so
ist es noch ein bisschen weit die Creme
kommt in der Zwischenzeit auch in den
Kühlschrank und nach der Kühlzeit zeige
ich euch wie ich das ganze dekoriere die
Kühlzeit ist oben wir können jetzt
unsere tiramisu-rolle hier einmal
komplett rausnehmen
übrigens auch ein gutes Rezept um das am
Vortag vorzubereiten ne dann habt ihr am
nächsten Tag gar keinen Stress wenn ihr
mal gestern empfangen
so ich habe jetzt hier so eine schöne
längliche Servierplatte durch das jetzt
drauf
erstmal nehme ich die Folie weg
gefüllt die brauchen wir nicht mehr
Stunde der Wahrheit ich meine es ist ja
egal es wird sowieso noch mal mit Creme
überdeckt aber ich trotzdem jetzt
unbedingt wissen
wie sie aussieht das sind immer wieder
so eine Überraschung ja sehr cool ich
finde es nackig auch nicht schlecht muss
ich sagen aber ich habe jetzt extra
Creme aufbewahrt weil ich dachte so
sieht einfach fertig aus so ich nehme
jetzt hier zwei hebe Paletten es ist
schon super weich ne ihr könntet das
eigentlich auch auf die Platte Socken
lassen ich glaube ich machst du so man
kann das Backpapier auch einfach per
wegreisen also macht euch da auf jeden
Fall keine Sorgen das funktioniert immer
irgendwie
[Musik]
so und jetzt nehmen wir uns die übrig
gebliebene Creme davon jetzt auch nicht
alles nehmen ihr könnt euch das ist
natürlich auch Geschmackssache wie ist
der kuriert aber ich finde immer schön
wenn man sich noch so ein bisschen was
so ungefähr vier fünf Esslöffel in einen
Spritzbeutel gibt zum Beispiel mit einer
Stern
und dann oben noch mal schön dekoriert
also das mache ich heute so ich gebe
dann noch frische Erdbeeren oben drauf
einfach so als Hinweis was ich dann auch
innen drin verbirgt und was ich auch
dazu nehme sind gefriergetrocknete
Früchte also ihr könnt
gefriergetrocknete Erdbeeren oder auch
Himbeeren nehmen und das dann auch noch
mal so als Deko oben drüber bröseln
lassen dass sie dann auch noch mal
richtig schön aus
[Musik]
dann wollen wir doch mal unsere Tiramisu
erdbeerrolle probieren ich glaube ihr
habt zu den endzähnen gesehen man kommt
da richtig locker durch also es wird
alles super super weiß
ah das ist ein Traum Leute es ist
überhaupt nicht schwer im Raum wirklich
überhaupt nicht also man hat es wirklich
weg das trifft wie die Faust aufs Auge
gerade für den Sommer perfekt geeignet
das ganze Jahr über so schnell gemacht
es sieht fancy aus und es ist super easy
also macht unbedingt nach falls ihr
meinen Kanal noch nicht abonniert gerne
nach und ich freue mich den Rest hier
auf jeden Fall noch zu teilen mit
Familie mit Freunden und dann sehen wir
uns auch beim nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]